[Music]
all right so we're going to move on to
the next question i know we spoke about
the image of the beast but
the mark of the beast all right
let's pray again father this is very
very serious material
please talk to me as i talk to your
people in jesus name i pray amen
go to ezekiel chapter nine
i let my friends online get that verse i
i i god bless all of you listening
revenue i really mean that whatever
country you're in state or neighborhood
god bless you
thank you for joining this program
ezekiel 9 we read from verse 4
ezekiel is seeing this vision of
judgment on jerusalem
and he hears a voice
talking to the destroying angel
he said and he says unto him go through
the midst of the city
through the midst of jerusalem and set a
mark upon foreheads of the men that cry
and sigh for all the abominations that
will be done in the midst they're all in
other words destroying angel don't
destroy those with the mark on their
foreheads i'm taking this there first so
we can understand we usually use the
word mark in connection with the beast
but god also has a mark you understand
we call it the seal but since i began by
saying the devil likes to copy god's
style of operation
god has a mark the devil has a mark
follow my sabbath it is a sign between
me and the children of israel forever
exodus 31 13-17 and so god has a mark or
a seal or a sign he has a mark the word
mark is used in easy
anyone with the mark don't touch that
person of course in revelation 7
we have the ceiling of god a mark is
placed on certain people 12 000 from
each tribe now
the mark of god the seal of god the
distinguishing outward distinguishing
mark and i use the word outward
deliberately is the seventh of the
sabbath observance
it is a sign ezekiel 20 verse 12 ezekiel
24 20 exodus 31 12-17 it is a sign
between god and his people it is not a
sign between god and the whole earth
between god and his people of course his
people can come from any ethnic group if
they will accept god's standards and
god's law now god's word ultimately
accept jesus christ
god has a mark it is the sabbath and i
said an outward mark by that i mean not
a mark on your forehead that you can see
but by the outward observance of the
sabbath the god's people are attending
church they're doing what god has to do
to avoid certain things on that day they
recognize that there's holy and by their
lifestyle people see that they're
observing the sabbath outward now god
had a second mark for the israelites
which was circumcision introduced in
genesis 17 but you cannot see
circumcision are you with me you can see
it now
circumcision therefore represents the
surrender of the heart to the the truth
of god and so we're told circumcise the
foreskin of your heart and be no more
hardheaded now
the sabbath keeping is the outward side
because what's in the heart must come
out you understand let me say it again
what's inside must come out circumcision
represents the cutting off of self and
total surrender to god servant's
observance is the outward expression of
that total surrender to god that's the
mark well satan's mark must be similar
his mark must be similar and as verily
as
god this god the father god the son god
the holy ghost there's the devil there's
the landline beast and there's the false
prophet then
sunday of sunday as a legal day of
worship is the mark of the beast as a
matter of fact in some catholic writings
it is stated plainly our power to change
the day from saturday to sunday is the
mark of our authority and our power and
so we as very if
daniel locked down of the three boys had
bound to that image they've accepted the
mark of of of nebuchadnezzar but by not
going they reflected the mark of god or
the seal of god
the beast has his mark and that is
sunday as a legal day of worship let me
i keep saying as a legal day because
right now no one has the mark of the
beast
we know what it is theoretically it is
not yet in practical operation
when a law is passed making sunday
worship the legal day of worship then we
will have in operation the mark of the
beast then we will have those those who
are wearing the mark of the beast based
on their conscious choice to follow a
manmade law in opposition to god's law
which says remember the sabbath day to
keep it holy
and so the mark of the beast is sunday
as a legal day of worship and enforced
by religious system using the secular
powers
that has not yet happened consequently
the mark of the beast is um
a biblical fact not yet operationalized
when that law is fair and it's coming
as it did for the three hebrew boys is
coming for us
then we will have the mark of the beast
in operation and those who accept that
man-made law will have the mark of the
beast those who continue to serve god
because first the heart has been given
to him they will have the seal of god
now the seventh-day sabbath is the seal
of god
sunday observance as a legal day
is the mark of the beast but no one has
the mark of the beast now because
universally there is no law requiring
sunday as the holy day
i say universally
amen amen thank you
and we but we must stop practicing you
see as you observe a day that god does
not require you are conditioning
yourselves to receive that mark when it
becomes a law and this is very important
you are it's like preparing for the
olympics you prepared four years the
olympics comes then you you're well
qualified to take part by constant
disobedience to god and rejecting his
day you make it easy for you to accept
the day when it becomes a lawful legal
holiday the violation of which will be
backed up by a death penalty
amen amen and friends this is how we
start connecting the questions because
remember we spoke about the united
states of america and its role as the
false prophet in setting up that image
will be very key in pushing for this
universal day of worship on sunday
and just to buttress what you have
shared elder steve i want to read these
excerpts of the first from priest brady
in an address reported in the news
elizabeth new jersey march 18 1903 and
this is an ecclesiastical review
february
1914 here's what it says
it is well to remind the presbyterians
baptists methodists and all other
christians that the bible does not
support them anywhere in their
observance of sunday
sunday is an institution of the roman
catholic church and those who observe
the day observe a commandment of the
catholic church
that's the first quotation
second quotation
they that is the protestants
deem it their duty to keep the sunday
holy why because the catholic church
tells them to do so they have no other
reason the observance of sunday thus
comes to be an ecclesiastical law
entirely distinct from the divine law of
sabbath observance yes the author of the
sunday law is the catholic church
and these are not my words that's right
these are quotations it's very simple
from what you said we can see how the
the beast has power supreme power
every
christian organization
observing sunday is obeying the catholic
church it is as simple as that because
sunday as a day of worship was not uh
brought into existence by the
presbyterians they did not exist or the
pentecostals did not exist or the
lutheran did not exist it was brought
into play by the roman church and every
church that adopts it is following the
catholic church and its authority it is
as simple as that
i don't care what they say about that
church
that church is honest in declaring we
change the day it's very honest and you
have to respect honesty those churches
that talk about the catholic church uh
and it's while observing sunday are
simply
not realizing they are obeying and they
are under the authority of the catholic
system because sunday's day of worship
is a product largely of the catholic
church
amen amen
and
just on a side note i know elder skeet
you had welcomed those who were tuning
in we actually had someone sister trisha
moses berkeley watching all the way from
trinidad and tobago oh god bless
trinidad and tobago
amen thank you and i'm sure we have
others listening listening in from other
countries god bless all those countries
with truth
amen amen
you